[Musique]
tout le monde sait que l'érotisme fleuri
au niveau des strapontins de pigalle
mais ceux qui vivent dans ce milieu
l'ont bien démystifier je vous les
ébranler c'est bien on va bien sûr enfin
pour le quartier vous vous la regardez
les films dc ou bouilli deux fois enfin
quand il ya des scènes qui sont
inférieurs et pour l'autre alors pour
venir qu'on regarde un petit peu vous
pourriez me raconter un scénario de ce
genre de film on pas vous savez c'est un
peu toujours pareil
il ya de toute façon il n'y a jamais de
fond c'est une histoire de c'est une
histoire de fesses il n'ya pas y revenir
bon eh bien c'est comme ça toulon
l'horizontale de ce que vous voulez ça
vous plaît mais abonnés baa - pas
personnellement mais ça plaît aux
clients c'est principal au bas on a eu
la masseuse perverse avec des étés venir
celui-là ça il a eu beaucoup de succès
les clients étaient emballés d'ailleurs
ils ont eu plusieurs fois vous avez des
habituels travail mais beaucoup on a des
habitués vous avez les personnes des
messieurs c'est de tous les premiers
rangs c'est leur place un autre c'est à
côté de la colonne enfin ou derrière
place et moi bien enfin tout et tout
évidemment nous avons quand même une
belle clientèle
on croit que dans des quartiers pareil
on a on n'a pas une belle clientèle
rassurez-vous nous avons sûrement des
pdg qui viennent dé monsieur très bien
mais ils aiment venir dans ce quartier
d'abord pour la bonne raison parce que
on ne s'occupe de personnes
et puis que ce soit un artiste parce que
nous avons des artistes aussi à venir
et qu'est ce qu'ils disent à leur femme
ou bien alors secrétaire quand ils
viennent ici est bien évidemment
ils viennent là d'abord ils sont à
l'abri parce que ici on s'occupe de
personnes mais des fois ça nous arrive
de demander ou clients mais au fait
qu'est ce que vous trouvez à ses films
vous messieurs puisque vous venez
souvent parce qu'il y en a qui viennent
plusieurs fois
alors monsieur m'a répondu oh vous savez
après le travail quand les affaires ont
mal marché on aime bien venir ici parce
que ça nous détend moi j'estime que si
ces messieurs vie à me rendre presque
services aux dames elles sont
tranquilles sont là ils ne sont pas à
boire au café ou qui sont très bien vécu
des mois georges de la fin je suis
qu'est ce qui se passe là et bien là
c'est la fin du pire on passe
actuellement
c'est les scènes un petit peu légère
bien entendu qu'est ce que vous pensez
de cette levée de boucliers contre les
films érotiques dans certaines villes de
france
écoutez
je crois que ces films érotiques dans un
certain sens nécessaire à condition
encore qu'ils ne soient pas trop poussé
on a beau dire on érotisme va s'en aller
va s'en aller c'est absolument faux il
en faudra toujours
et puis au fond faut pas voir le mal
n'est pas bon voire voir voir ces deux
mamans dire une paire de fesses et alors
c'est pas un drame et vous avez beaucoup
de femmes n'ont très peut de toute façon
quand il en vient
elles sont pas critiqués femme samia pas
y revenir elle arrive dans la salle rôle
dit je m'excuse mademoiselle je n'ai
même pas regardé ce qu'on joue tu parles
saison paris avec ce qu'on est obligé ça
vous n'allez pas me dire que comme vous
voyez un hall avec des photos presque
porno que dans la salle on va jouer
blanche-neige jours
c'est bien draps
jours qu'on critique les films érotiques
mais on fait complet avec des films
érotiques comment voulez vous qu'on
pense aux au début faut dire le mot ça
va peut-être choquer un peu mais
maintenant ça me fait carrément vire a
carrément rire pourquoi 20 pas parce que
je me dis quand même faut tout de même
peu de choses pour amuser les autres
[Musique]